[Musique]
le procureur de la haute saône a été
appelé par les gendarmes pour une
attaque à l'explosif sur un distributeur
de billets à gré une heure de voiture
depuis le hall mines priorité de se
rendre sur le terrain surtout dans cette
ville tristement marqué par une autre
histoire
[Musique]
grèce et d'une ville ça et je passe
beaucoup de temps et j'ai beaucoup
d'attention parce que c'est lui qui
était vraiment traumatisé par la sphère
alex et d'aval et il ya toujours la
barre authentiquement très fort et qui a
fait délinquance grave qui s'y produit
j'ai salué les bons jours bonjour
bonjour alors je vous écoute alors 1h17
donc chez les gendarmes car les premiers
et gendarmes quand même les premiers
ouais la partie écran lui dame a été
projetée de l'autre côté de la rue où il
ya des personnes qui ont entendu des
choses il ya trois témoins qui ont été
réveillés par le souffle de l'explosion
nous sommes rendus à l'intérieur et que
vous aurez pu constater que l'intérieur
de l'agencé détruits par le souffle de
l'explosif qui a été utilisé là on
efface effectivement de la criminalité
organisée
puisqu'il faut avoir une très grande
technicité pour utiliser des explosifs
donc ce sera le but effectivement dans
quai de voir si on est sur un phénomène
sérielle qui s'est déroulée sur
l'ensemble de la région
même si la haute saône est un
département rural le grand banditisme il
fait parler de lui
il faut être vigilant et occuper le
terrain
[Musique]
retour à vesoul cette fois à la
gendarmerie pour une mission
particulière avec le contrôle des choses
[Musique]
par son statut le procureur contrôler
visite une fois par an cette unité de la
gendarmerie la brigade motorisée
l'occasion d'échanger sur le quotidien
des gendarmes
l'actuel mandat 81 18 accidents oms tués
et 109 blessés
moi les refus d'obtempérer là il faut
qu'il soit différé parce que on a eu des
mises en danger de vous au palais de
justice
la vie suit son cours autre acteur
essentiel dans la vie de cette
juridiction
le juge d'instruction le juge
d'instruction n'enquête pas de sa propre
initiative une enquête uniquement dans
le cadre juridique que lui aura donné
pro car la république juge d'instruction
il travaille devenir autonome sans
aucune hiérarchie réalisation est
contrainte dans des pouvoirs d enquête
le procureur va gérer aussi tout ce qui
est tout venant alors que moi en vain le
juge d'instruction gère que les dossiers
complexes
oui monsieur des pics à la part de
monsieur nous poussons une dernière fois
la porte de permanence du parquet hier
pour découvrir de nouvelles histoires
qu'il va falloir entendre jugez vous
avez interrompt interpellé voire vous
aviez consommer les produits stupéfiants
j'ai revécu poker vous n'avez pas
l'autorisation de conduire c'est une
amende
vous avez déjà refusé le contrôle
chapeau bas monsieur qui est sous tel
michael sata qui est soudainement un
monsieur qui se foutent
merci à un contrôle de gendarmerie ça
oui mais je voulais pas que mes enfants
au passage j'ai préféré m'arrêter pour
que mes enfants qui voyant pas que je me
fais arrêter vous poser pour lui
souffler après j'ai soufflé et après là
monsieur qui a commencé à parler un peu
ce texte ou cinq qui n'a pas trop purgé
10 je n'ai pas d'elle les tests comme
vous avez déjà été condamnés notamment à
la prison ferme que vous avez commis
deux infractions
vous avez une peine de six mois de
prison à faire 6 mois de prison ça veut
dire vous allez rencontrer un juge
d'application des peines et il va
décider effectivement quand une
situation si ç'avait najab ou pas
délinquance routière violences
conjugales grand banditisme
la société a ses travers qu'il faut
recadrer punir c'est un travail de tous
les jours depuis le 1er janvier la
justice a évolué ne parle plus de
tribunal d'instance de grande instance
mais de tribunal judiciaire
une justice qui essaye de se simplifier
[Musique]